you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video 17
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and I'd like to share with you
an important information and rook pawn
those of you who have been connected
with me for some time may recall I've
already covered this topic nearly five
years ago do know that there will only
be a handful of topics I revisit
specifically for this playlist and this
happens to be one of them and in this
video I've included some additional
features also at the end I have a little
pop quiz for you a group of five
multiple-choice questions and one bonus
type question I guess we can say one
that is of the find the best
continuation type so with that said
let's have a look at our first of just a
handful of examples where in this
position it's white to move and just to
be clear in all examples I share with
you in this video it will be white to
move so let's see what it is white does
in our first example
why does improving their king position
the white king will soon be helpful in
escorting the white pawn to promotion
land meanwhile what is it that the black
King has done what is it that the black
King continues to do well
the black king went to the corner and
the black King continues to simply stay
near the corner simple enough
interesting position we have here
interesting because one wrong step by
white and the game's over what do I mean
well suppose a seven game over stalemate
woo we don't want to do that we have an
extra bishop we have a pond we're trying
to win here's why let's try something
else
Bishop f4 well that's not very good
attempt is it it's another stalemate we
don't want to go there suppose we make a
passing move like Bishop d2 let's try
this so that after King b8 at least we
can now push this pawn it's not
stalemate in this case however after
king a8 now what what should white do
King a6 yet another case of stalemate
hmm let's try something else
King b5 King c5 King c6 King takes pawn
draw not enough mating material hmm
let's try something else
suppose Bishop e3 White's being clever
now king b8 a7 king a8 and now we get to
move our King have our pawn defended and
it not be stalemate
King b7 but what do we do is white how
do we make progress how do we flush the
King out of the corner King a5 King a
gate King a6 stalemate hmm every way we
look at it seems to be stalemate King c4
King d5 King d6 and if we even dare
approach the black King by way of c6 or
c7 yet another case or two of stalemate
however we look at it stalemates all
over white cannot win even though white
has an extra pawn and Bishop is this
always the case no here is what you need
to know about this endgame what I'm
about to share with you involves the
rook pawns and the rook pawns alone it
could be just one Rick pawn it can be
multiple rook pawns okay if the
defending sides king can get to the
corner square and the bishop cannot
control the corner square it's a draw it
is said in this position that white has
the wrong colored bishop he has a bishop
that cannot control the a8 square he's a
dark square bishop we would need in this
position a light square bishop in order
for it to be a win again if the
defending sides King can get to the
corner square and the bishop cannot
control the corner square that promotion
square in other words it's a draw let's
have a look at an example where we're
working with a light square bishop
actually before I even show you that
have a look at this this example real
quick not even going to make a move look
at this one
pretty weird huh why would we promote a
couple of our pawns to become bishops
yeah we have a lot of material here but
guess what even this position here is a
draw we don't have the correct color
Bishop we have three I guess we can say
wrong colored bishops and it doesn't
matter how many rook pawns we have it's
just not going to work out
even this position here is a draw maybe
one you could throw up against your
computer and have some fun see what it
says
but yeah this position is also a draw
let's have a look at our next example
uh-huh working with a different color
Bishop that's the only thing that's
really changed here let's see how things
turn out
white King is helpful in pushing the
pond and the pond gets all the way up to
that sixth rank and now what well we
could play a seven the king is in check
and if he goes to the corner now Bishop
g2 check mate simple enough right
where else is the King to go here we got
a queen hmm what else if it happened to
be let's say King goes here and then
here if in this position we don't want
to push the pawn that's stalemate right
now but we could first insert the bishop
check first just switch the move order a
little bit Bishop g2 check King b8 now
we push the king is flushed away from
the corner and now we can successfully
promote that pawn because we are working
with the correct colored bishop we have
a bishop that can control the corner
square the promotion square
that's the big idea with this end game
okay let's have a look at another
example here we go in this position it
is white to move white can win this but
needs to be accurate with their very
next move Bishop f4 this stops the King
from getting to b8 and if he's not
getting to b8 he's not getting to the
corner again keep in mind those
conditions if the defending sides King
can get to the corner and the bishop
cannot control that corner square it's a
draw
unfortunately the King can't get to the
corner both of those conditions need to
be in place in order for it to be a drop
the king isn't getting to the corner in
this case and so what white is able to
do is simply push right through to get a
queen king is in a fantastic position
white controls that square the pond
simply runs to get a queen that's a way
to win we cut the King off from even
getting to the corner let's have a look
at just two more examples and I have a
couple games to share with you here we
go one that I played when I was not even
15 years old here we go
like to move here notice if black only
had a rip on
this isn't the correct color bishop it
does not control that queening square h1
so a good idea for white is to give
check forking the king and super
valuable G pawn and now we can sacrifice
our knight for this guy and simply get
to the corner because we know that black
will not be able to win this this will
turn out to be a draw as we have already
seen black does not have the correct
color bishop let's have a look at just
one more example and then I will soon
enough be putting you to the test white
to move here here's a clever move notice
black if a black was only working with
rook pawns black does not have the
correct colored Bishop Bishop to a4 and
with this move light will be able to
successfully remove the knight pawned
the beep on there's a little pin going
on here and if the bishop is captured
again it doesn't matter how many rook
puns you have here black doesn't have
the correct color Bishop this is a draw
if black tries something else like
doesn't take the bishop well we're
taking here pretty much out to just take
them right we're getting to the corner
yet again a draw on board now let's just
see a couple examples of this idea
showing up in a game and I guess we'll
visit the game I played first not going
to be commenting on any of my moves but
maybe you'll find it a little bit
interesting I guess along the way to see
how I was playing as not even a 15 year
old I was playing somebody who was 1900
bring it up here flip the board there we
go so I'm just going to zip through here
and we'll see how I was eight I was
familiar with this with this idea this
end game idea I'm playing black here I
was about mid 1500 and eventually I get
into a losing position but my opponent
doesn't find a way there were plenty of
different ways I could have been killed
in this one but the game continues for
some time and eventually I'm able to
make use of this idea I was familiar
with this idea and actually my opponent
was not I don't have the full game
eventually I think I was low on time as
far as I could recall go figure right I
know you stopped keeping notation but
you'll basically get the idea what I'm
trying to do here is find a way to
eliminate both the G and H pawns and my
opponent allowed me to take the Jeep on
and I just took the H pawn next because
I knew white had what the wrong colored
bishop even if I don't have my beep um
this will be a draw I don't have the
rest of the moves of this game but from
what I recall my opponent I don't know I
think it was just kind of from his body
language he was kind of stunned that he
couldn't make progress around here and
there was a little bit of back and forth
and eventually realized there isn't a
way forward yeah it's a draw so that's a
little way you could kind of you know
simplify to this endgame being familiar
with this idea of having the round
collared Bishop you can be looking for
ways to try and eliminate these guys
here and my opponent shouldn't have
allowed me to do these kind of things it
was losing for some time but I was aware
of this idea I was able to take those
guys out and then run to the corner and
hold the draw hold the point and there's
even one other more recent game
Karlsson versus way recent game that was
played
we had an end game that also made use of
this wrong colored bishop idea and that
is this position right here a little bit
more complicated of course a lot of
pawns and still a lot of pawns on board
Carlson was playing as white he played a
four and soon we have wayy taking out
the beep on notice that if white has
this rook pawn he does not have the
correct colored bishop to control that
promotion square let's see how this game
finished
this was from 2016 tournament a Bilbao
masters final king
excuse me Knight to h4 after Knight
takes f3 in this position removing the F
pawn they already agreed to a drop both
players clearly well aware of this idea
of white having in this case the wrong
colored bishop he cannot control this
square and it will go on to be a drum so
with that let's dive right in and I'm
going to throw this little pop quiz at
you and see how you do if you'd like to
get out a little piece of paper for
these first five questions your answers
are either going to be it's a white one
it's a black wind that should be pretty
easy to determine which side is trying
to win a white win a black win or a draw
I'm initially just going to go through
all five questions and then I will
revisit each and excuse me all five
questions and then the bonus question
and then I will revisit each and give
you the answers in some cases a little
bit of explanation so here is the first
pop quiz question here we go again
in each of these it is white to move so
feel free to pause the video and spend
as much time with each of these three to
one okay moving on now to pop quiz
question number two here we go three two
one here comes pop quiz question number
three three two one here comes number
four three two one
and the last multiple-choice one
question five three two one
and now the bonus question there we go
so again this for this bonus question
like to move what is the best
continuation what is let's say the
cleanest continuation making use of this
idea we just learned about having the
wrong colored Bishop light to move
okay now with that I'm now going to
revisit and share the answers and again
in some cases maybe an explanation or
two so let's see how you did
question number one the answer to this
is it's a draw the king can get the
defending sides King can get to the
corner square and the bishop cannot
control the corner square we're working
with the rook pawn this is a draw
question number two we're not even
working with the rook pawn who cares
what color squared the bishop is on this
is a win again this idea is for rook
pawns and Rapunzel own question three
this is a win the bishop can play to d5
stop the King from even getting to the
corner and then push through number four
this may have tricked you I don't know
this is a win it may be tempting to just
kind of look at it as oh I could do this
similar idea you know I shared an
example where the knight could
fork the king and pawn and after the
king moves we get this pawn but in the
end is this the correct color bishop it
is the correct color bishop he can
control that corner square that
promotion square therefore this is a
winning position of course white doesn't
have to go in for that you could do some
other stuff but this is a one end game
there isn't this saving idea where the
knight can sacrifice himself for one of
the pawns and it be a draw this is this
will be a one position for black the
last multiple choice question is well
what's the answer to this one this here
is also a win for black hmm I wonder who
maybe got slipped up with this one you
may have been too focused on this move
Bishop h4 thinking aha
when my bishops captured I just get to
the corner and it's a draw unfortunately
black doesn't have to take the bishop so
this is worth noting right if you happen
to be in a position like this and your
opponent's throwing out a bishop like
that you need to know you need to
preserve your knight pawn your G pawn in
this case and if you're going to have
any try to win black in this case
doesn't have to take the bishop black in
this case should not capture the bishop
and instead move the King move this pawn
save the knight pawn for sure and help
out get your Bishop around this will go
on I don't want to go into the details
but just know that this will be a one
position white does not have this
resource of sacrificing the bishop for
the knight pawn in this case bishop here
King there Bishop takes pawn how do you
recapture not with the King
on takes we need a knight pawn in this
case if black wants to win and though
the last question the bonus question
might have been there isn't just one way
to go ahead and win this but I believe
that the cleanest approach in this this
one here is to simply capture the knight
right we could maybe see something like
this happen in in in a game right where
there's many different capturing
possibilities Knight takes Knight Knight
takes bishop maybe we capture this pawn
well in this position we shouldn't care
so much about winning that pawn we know
this idea of the black having a round
colored bishop in this case dark square
bishop the h1 square is a light square
what we can do being down some material
here is white
capture the night
takes Knight Bishop a3 if you went for
this variation this is the cleanest
approach we're giving check we're taking
out the e pawn and we're simply running
to the corner and this will also turn
out to be a draw so with that as usual
feel free to leave any feedback to this
video let me know how you did with these
five multiple choice questions in the
bonus question any any of you go let's
say six for six feel free to leave any
feedback let me know how you did in the
comment section below and as usual I
hope you got something out this video
that's all for now take care bye